So we've talked about some probability problems
that we can handle with simulation--that is,
choosing using a random number generator,
some samples, and hoping that they're representative of the problem.
And if you choose enough, you get a close enough representation.
An alternative strategy is enumeration,
where we actually go over all the possibilities
and we can compute an exact probability.
Now, some problems are so complex that it would take forever to do that,
but computers are much better at it than people are,
and so it's a powerful strategy.
We'll show you some simple examples, and they can scale up to more complex ones.
So let's imagine all the possible families living in houses,
and these houses have differeing poperties.
This one is colored red and has an Englishman.
This one has a zebra, and so on.
But for now we're only interested in the children that live in those houses,
and, in fact, we're only interested in the houses that have exactly 2 children.
So we're going to not consider some of them,
and consider the other ones that have exactly 2 children,
and then we want to be able to ask questions of them.
And we can ask probability questions.
We're going to constrain ourselves to ask conditional probability questions.
So what is the probability of Event A given Event B?
And an event is just a state of affairs.
So Event B might be the event of the family having exactly 2 children.
And so we've crossed off these houses,
and we're only taking these other ones, and then Event A might be
the probability of having a boy or a girl.
Now, in real life, we could do simulation by going out and polling and asking people.
In mathematics, we can do enumeration if we make certain assumptions,
and one assumption we can make is that it's exactly 50% probable that you get a boy
and 50% probable that you get a girl and that one birth
is independent from another.
So let's address the question.
What's the probability of having 2 boys given that there is at least 1 boy in the family?
And the universe of possibilities is only the families that have exactly 2 children.
So we could put that here in the condition as well--
at least 1 boy and 2 children total.
What do you think this probability is equal to?
Let's put your answer here and enter it in the form of a fraction.
So if you think it's one-half, put 1 and then 2.
If you think it's 11-17ths, put 11 and 17.